this is my secret of life you guys
listen up guys
Kim Kardashian is sharing her secret of
life and it's all about drumroll please
melted Eminem's yeah
like the chocolate candy that melts in
your mouth not in your hand to me this
is a no-brainer let's rewind the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star revealed
one of her greatest life hacks on
Twitter responding to this users pick of
a jar of green and red M&Ms she wrote
quote put them on a plate then in the
microwave for 30 seconds and it will
change your life melt it on the inside
and crunch on the outside it just is
such a life changer a day later she
posted this video to Twitter giving fans
a full rundown on her super important
candy eating method love it when they
crack okay they're just warm and gushy
on the inside if you put them in the
microwave for 30 seconds so the goal
look at that is to be warm and melty on
the inside but crunchy on the inside I
mean crunchy on the outside this is my
secret of life you guys it's so
satisfying in your mouth please try it
someone okay but Kim isn't the only
Kardashian with weird chocolate eating
habits I would never even dream to eat a
KitKat and just like bite it into it in
2016
Courtney shared her six simple steps to
eating a KitKat yes six steps I am gonna
show you guys something that Kim taught
me I think we were like seven and eight
how to eat a KitKat and it's pretty
life-changing yep she said life-changing
too
first you break off the piece
eat the chocolate off the end you eat
the chocolate down each side and then
you pull the top layer off and eat that
and then you separate it again
you eat the bottom piece and then the
best part and the whole KitKat is the
middle piece and that's it and in 2015
Chloe shared the secret behind her super
organized cookie jar you know what you
say OCD is a disease I say it's a
blessing you heard that right
organized cookie jar so we are just
gonna place all the way around on the
edge and we're gonna work our way in oh
and it gets crazier and I do this once a
month so because obviously things go bad
so every 30 days I just know the first
of every month like you pay your rent
you're gonna redo your cookie jars hello
it's been normal these girls take their
sweets so seriously Kim and Kourtney
even got into a fight over a joint candy
land birthday party they were throwing
for their daughters North and Penelope
okay I'm gonna do it somewhat healthy
like she was gonna have this like
Candyland Kourtney it's not gonna be
healthy
but nobody wants Kourtney yes it can
Kourtney has this vision no sugar or no
disgusting chemicals and candy it's like
a completely sugar-free gluten-free
party free fun free zone because
Kourtney has decided that it just
doesn't make sense and it really wasn't
the theme of what North and Penelope
wanted for their birthday well Kim got
her way and the party was a sugary smash
[Music]